MORNING
LET'S BRING IN OUR CNN NATIONAL
I WAS WATCHING THE COVERAGE
BEFORE THE TOWN HALL STARTED.
YOU WERE ONE OF THE FINAL VOICES
ON.
WE SAW EXACTLY WHO THE FORMER ;
a
PRESIDENT WAS AND STILL IS LAST
NIGHT.
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
GOOD MORNING, POPPY AND PHIL.
PERHAPS NO SURPRISE.
IT WAS THE SAME TUNE.
THE SECOND ACT EFFECTIVELY THE ;
a
SAME AS THE FIRST.
AIRING OLD GRIEVANCES AND ;
a
.
ALREADY WON THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION, SPENDING ALMOST NO
TIME ON THE GOP RIVALS OR TRYIN;
a
WANTS TO DEFY HISTORY AND RETURN
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Reporter: FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP PICKED UP RIGHT ;
a
WHERE HE LEFT OFF, LYING ABOUT ;
.
>> THAT WAS A RIGGED ELECTION.
IT'S A SHAME THAT WE HAD TO GO ;
a
.
>> TRUMP MADE CLEAR HIS 2024 ;
a
PRESIDENTIAL BID WOULD FOLLOW ;
PREVIOUS CAMPAIGNS, SAYING HE IS
A MESSENGER UNBURDENED BY FACTS;
a
.
>> YOU WOULD US IS SPENT ;
a
POLARIZING TALK OF ELECTION
FRAUD DURING YOUR RUN FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> YEAH
UNLESS I SEE ELECTION FRAUD.;
a
THE IF I SEE ELECTION FRAUD, I
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO SAY IT.;
a
MIKE PENCE COULD HAVE ACTED TO
OVERTURNT ELECTION RESULTS AS
THE VOTE WAS CERTIFIED ON
JANUARY 6.
TRUMP SAID HE DID NOT OWE PENCE
AN APOLOGY FOR FAILING TO CALL ;
a
OFF SUPPORTERS WHO THREATENED
HIS LIFE AS THEY STORMED THE
BUILDING.
>> NO, BECAUSE HE DID SOMETHING;
a
.
HE SHOULD HAVE PUT THE VOTES ;
a
AND I THINK WE WOULD HAVE HAD A;
.
>> MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, WHEN ;
a
YOU PARDON THE JANUARY 6th
RIOTERS WHO WERE CONVICTED OF ;
a
FEDERAL OFFENSES --
>> I'M INCLINED TO PARDON MANY ;
a
OF THEM
I CAN'T SAY FOR EVERY SINGLE
ONE.
A COUPLE OF THEM PROBABLY THEY ;
a
GOT OUT OF CONTROL.
>> THE AUDIENCE OF REPUBLICAN
VOTERS SAY THE COLLEGE APPLAUD ;
a
FORD MUCH OF THE NIGHT.
EVEN AS TRUMP BELITTLED AND ;
a
DEMEANED FORMER MAGAZINE
COLUMNIST E. JEAN CARROLL AFTER;
a
Y
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHO SHE S
SHE'S A WHACK JOB.
>> PRESSED BY WHETHER THE ;
a
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> YET, SOME REPUBLICANS BELIEVE
OTHERWISE.
WHEN NEW HAMPSHIRE GOVERNOR
CHRIS SUNUNU WHO IS CONSIDERING;
a
WILL BE PHASED BY ANYTHING.
>> SEVEN MONTHS AFTER THE VOTING
BEGINS, TRUMP IS LEADING THE
FIELD.
EVEN AS HE FACES MULTIPLE LEGAL
CHANGES OVER INTERFERING IN THE;
a
.
>> I JUST WANT TO FIND --
>> HE STRUCK A DEFENSIVE TONE
ABOUT THAT CALL TO THE GEORGE ;
a
JORN
GEORGIA SECRETARY OF STATE, ;
a
.
IF THIS CALL IS BAD, WHY DIDN'T;
a
HIM AND HIS LAWYERS HANG UP?;
HOW DARE YOU SAY THAT?
>> THEY WERE CONCERNED ENOUGH ;
a
THEY RECORDED THE CALL.
>> HE BRUSHED ASIDE QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANOTHER PROBE INCLUDING ;
a
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TAKING TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> WHETHER IT COMES TO YOUR
DOCUMENTS, DID YOU EVER SHOW ;
a
THOSE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
ANYONE?
I WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO.;
a
BY THE WAY, THEY WERE
DECLASSIFIED AFTER --
NOT THAT I CAN THINK OF.;
a
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO DO WHATEVER I
WANT WITH THEM.
I HAVE THE RIGHT.
>> THAT, OF COURSE, REMAINS AN ;
a
AND A KEY PART OF A FEDERAL
>> TRUMP TOOK PERSONAL CREDIT ;
a
FOR THE SUPREME COURT DECISION
OVERTURNING ROE VERSUS WADE ;
a
E
HIGH COURT.
>> I WAS HONORED TO DO IT.
>> HE REPEATEDLY DODGED
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER HE WOULD
SIGN A FEDERAL ABORTION BAN.;
a
THAT'S GOING TO WORK.
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE FOR THE ;
a
.
>> ON FOREIGN POLICY, TRUMP ONCE
AGAIN SHOWED AFFINITY FOR ;
a
DECLINING TO CALL FOR PUNISHMEN;
>> IF YOU SAY HE'S A WAR
CRIMINAL, IT WILL BE A LOT
TOUGHER TO MAKE A DEAL TO GET
THIS THING STOPPED.
>> HE ALSO DECLINED TO SAY WHO
HE WANTS TO PREVAIL IN THE WAR.
DESPITE THE U.S. AND ALLIES
INVESTING BILLIONS TO HELP ;
a
.
>> DO YOU WANT UKRAINE TO WIN ;
a
?
>> I DON'T THINK IN TERMS OF ;
a
WINNING AND LOSING.
I THINK IN TERMS OF SETTLED SO
WE STOP KILLING ALL THE PEOPLE.;
a
PROCESS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT REPUBLICAN
RIVALS ARE DOING AS THEY POINT
OUT THAT IS STILL THE BEGINNING
OF THE ROAD.
THERE ARE SOME SEVEN MONTHS OR
SO BEFORE THE VOTING BEGINS.;
a
Y
CLOSE ATTENTION TO THIS TOWN
HALL LAST NIGHT SAYING THAT THE;
a
FLOON D
PLAN TO DO ADVERTISING ON.
RON DeSANTIS, HE IS HE HAD HE
SHOULD SIMPLY STAY HOME AND NOT;
a
.
OF COURSE THAT, IS IT NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
HE'S JUMPING INTO THIS RACE,
WE'RE TOLD, IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS.
SO, A LOT TO DIGEST THERE.
BUT AGAIN THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION.
IT'S NOT THE END.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT.
>> WHAT IS NOW TO DISCUSS, OUR ;
a
CORRESPONDENT JOINING US, CNN ;
NATIONAL POLITICS REPORT EASTER;
a
CNN SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST AND
FORMER STATE PROSECUTOR.;
a
CRITICAL POINT MUCH IT'S EARLY.;
.
THIS IS CLEARLY BY THE NUMBERS ;
a
BE THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR ;
.
WHEN YOU WATCH THIS AND TOOK IT
IN AND THOUGHT THROUGH 2024, ;
a
WHAT CAME TO MIND?
>> ALL OF US KNOW THIS FROM
BEING OUT ON THE TRAIL.
THE BIGGEST, I THINK, JOB FOR A
CANDIDATE IS ENGAGE AND BRING IN
NEW VOTERS.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'VE BEEN ON THE
SCENE A WHILE.
THAT IS HIS JOB.
WHETHER HE WANTS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT OR NOT, HE LOST THE LAST
ELECTION.
>> BY SEVEN MILLION VOTES.
>> YES.
AND IF HE'S TRYING TO WIN THE
NEXT ONE, HE HAS TO GET FOLKS
THAT DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM BEFORE;
a
TO NOW VOTE FOR HIM THIS TIME.
AND, YOU KNOW, WATCHING THAT ;
a
FOLD.
YES, THAT ENTIRE EPISODE REALLY
STROKED HIS EGO.
HE WAS WITH A VERY FAVORABLE ;
a
.
YOU KNOW THAT HE THRIVES IN THI;
a
.
IN THIS TYPE OF SITUATION WHERE
HIS EGO IS STROKED.
BUT WHAT NEW VOTERS DID HE
T
ATTRACT LAST NIGHT?
>> I WONDER IF HE LOST SOME
REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE OF HIS ANSWE;
a
ON WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE DOBBS ;
.
a
AND THEN WOULD NOT ANSWER HER ;
QUESTION ABOUT WOULD HE SIGN A ;
a
?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU WONDER WHAT ;
a
THAT MEANS.
THAT'S WHAT THE PERFORMANCE WAS
LAST NIGHT N A GENERAL ELECTION;
a
THAT STANCE ON ABORTION IS
LOOKING AT THE GENERAL ELECTION;
a
SIGNED A SIX-WEEK ABORTION BAN
IN FLORIDA.
DONALD TRUMP WON'T SAY IF HE'LL;
a
RAISE THE ABORTION BAN.
THIS IS AN ISSUE EVEN THOUGH HE;
a
APPOINTED AJUSTICES, EVEN THOUGH
HE CLAIMED THIS WAS A GREAT ;
a
.
HE HAS EXPRESSED PRIVATELY HERE
THAT ABORTION IS AN ISSUE THAT ;
a
HE BLAMED IT FOR THE LOSS THAT';
.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS
INTERESTING ON THE ABORTION
ISSUE.
I THINK IT IS ONE OF THE MOMENTS
YOU COULD ACTUALLY ALMOST SEE
THE POLITICAL CALCULATION IN
DONALD TRUMP'S HEAD.
HE RAN FOR THE PRESIDENCY IN ;
a
OVERTURN ROE VERSUS WADE.;
>> YES, THE LESLEY STAHL
INTERVIEW ON "60 MINUTES.";
a
.
THEY DID JUST THAT.
THEY ISSUED THE DOBBS DECISION.;
a
ARGUMENT THAT HE WAS MAKING THA;
HE DELIVERED ON.
NOW, LAST NIGHT, IT SEEMS LIKE
SOMEONE SAID IF THEY BRING
UP
ABORTION, SAY NEGOTIATION.;
a
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
NEGOTIATION OF WHAT?
I THINK HE SEE THERE'S IS SOME
POLITICAL RISK THERE NOW.;
a
.
HE WATCHED WISCONSIN AND ;
a
.
HE WATCHED 2022 AND THE ELECT ;
a
RAT AND HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSU;
.
LOOK, WHAT HE SAID ON DOBBS ;
a
.
I DON'T THINK CAN YOU PARSE
WHERE YOU LAND ON THAT DESPITE
THIS UNWILLINGNESS TO ANSWER
FIVE DIFFERENT FOLLOW UPS FROM
IT KAITLAN ON THIS ISSUE.
YOU TAKE A STEP BACK.
YOU TALK TO DEMOCRATS WHO WERE
WATCHING, REGARDLESS OF THE
VIEWS OF THE TOWN HALL, THEY'LL;
a
ALL SAY WE HAVE LOADS OF CONTEN;
.
PLAY THIS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> YOU SAW THAT RUSHING THE ;
a
CAPITOL, BREAKING WINDOWS,
HITTING OFFICERS WITH FLAG ;
a
WHEN IT WAS CLEAR THEY WEREN'T
BEING PEACEFUL, WHY DID YOU WAIT
THREE HOURS TO TELL THEM TO ;
a
LEAVE THE CAPITOL?
THEY LISTEN YOU TO LIKE NO ONE ;
a
ELSE.
>> THEY DO.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
>> SO WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL THEM ;
a
?
>> NANCY PELOSI AND THE MAYOR
ARE IN CHARGE.
I ASSUMED THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOB.
>> BUT PELOSI IS NOT IN CHARGE.
>> I WAS THERE ON JANUARY 6.
I WAS PERSONALLY ENRAGED BY WHAT
HE IS SAYING.
YOU THINK THERE IS LEGAL ;
a
?
.
CAITLYN SAYS CLEARLY, THOSE ;
a
PEOPLE LISTEN TO YOU, YOU KNOW ;
.
HE SAID, YES.
YES, I DO.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
IF YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT ;
a
RELATION TO THE EFFORT TO STEAL
THE ELECTION, YOU NEED TO SHOW ;
a
THAT CONNECTION.
DONALD TRUMP KNEW AND UNDERSTOO;
a
HE UNDERSTOOD THAT PEOPLE WOULD;
LISTEN TO HIM AND DO THING
BECAUSE HE SAID SO AND STOP ;
a
DOING THINGS BECAUSE HE SAID SO;
I NEVER HEARD HIM SO CLEARLY ;
a
ADMIT THAT.
EVERYTHING DONALD TRUMP SAYS IS;
a
.
IT'S FAIR GAME.